[Music]
now for something completely different
or maybe not that different we've been
talking about the move from promises to
bargains the contracts the basis of
contract is mutual promises but not
every promise leads to a contract for
instance promises in which the person
who makes the promise or in law is
called the promise or doesn't expect to
find himself in court and in this
situation like the invitation to dinner
shouldn't end up in court and you
remember Leonard against PepsiCo with a
Harrier jet that's another example by
and large and later on we'll see some
very important exceptions to this by and
large the class of promises serious
promises if you like let's call them
public promises not private promises or
joke promises or gift promises the law
goes further in that class and says in
order to be sure this is serious
business that the parties are serious
about it and that it's worth our taking
our time in court and judges and so on
it's best that the promise be part of a
bargain that is a promise given for
something here are two straightforward
examples I go into a store and pick up
some Goods and I promise to pay for them
they've given me the goods and I've
given them my promise to pay fine a
contract or I go into an antique shop
and see an old desk I like I promise to
buy it to pay for it and the shop owner
promises to deliver it to my house next
week he's got to polish it up and
he doesn't have a delivery truck just
now and so on for there to be a bargain
there has to be something exchanged
something given on each side in the
first case the goods in the store paid
for at the checkout counter in that case
it's a promise for a performance
I think the goods then in there or it's
a promise for a promise promise to pay
for the desk and the promise to deliver
the desk either way there's an exchange
now the person who initiates the
exchange can set the terms of the
exchange that's what makes him the offer
or I offer the exchange and the other
side who sometimes in law is called the
offeree he accepts any accepts either by
accepting through making a promise of
his own or maybe by an actual
performance now when he says a promise
of his own for him to say yes that
counts as a promise will you promise to
do this yes by the way it could be a
performance in return for a promise so I
can give the antique dealer the $500
that's the performance and he can
promise to deliver that's a performance
for a promise
either way it's bilateral and the
contract is formed when the offer is
accepted what happens if I offer to buy
this desk this beautiful old desk and I
say I'll buy this desk for $500 the
antique dealer says I'd be glad to sell
it to you for 750 is that a bargain well
it obviously isn't imagine if the buyer
was somehow compelled now to pay 750
dollars and get the desk that wouldn't
be right at all because the Buy
the offer or has stated his terms I will
promise to pay $500 for the desk but I
haven't offered to pay whatever you
charge that would be a ridiculous thing
to do and that illustrates that in order
for the antique dealer to accept the
promise he's got to accept the offer I
made he can't accept some other offer
that he might wish I had made and the
way that the law of contracts puts it is
the offer or is the master of the
bargain that sounds rather dramatic but
it's only common sense how could it be
otherwise how could it be otherwise then
that the bargain is whatever the person
who initiates it proposes and what the
person to whom it is proposed accepts if
the person accepts something else then
obviously there is no bargain and the
idea that I would be bound just by
walking into the store and offering
something to then have to pay a great
deal more is not the model of an
exchange that we've been talking about